[Musique]
oh
ça me bel et bien hélas dans une
cinquième vague épidémique la cinquième
vague et bien là on vous apprend rien la
cinquième vague est là et en plus elle
est accompagnée du variant au micro
arrivé tout droit d'afrique australe se
mariant à muter de nombreuses fois 32 au
moment où nous filmons cette vidéo et
détient le record du nombre de mutations
de sa protéine spahic c'est la protéine
qui s'accroche à nos cellules et si ce
n'est pas encore très clair pour vous
vous invite à aller voir cet épisode de
factures avec pfizer moderna on va
entraîner les cellules de notre corps à
se défendre contre le virus alors en
réponse à l'émergence de ce nouveau
variant appelé omicron donc la
communauté internationale a décidé
d'appliquer des restrictions de voyage à
nouveau la plus redoutée d'entre elles
serait la fermeture des frontières mais
est-elle réellement efficace pour lutter
contre la propagation du côté de
[Musique]
19,6 l'épidémie est déjà installée sur
le territoire il serait logiquement trop
tard voire inutile de fermer les
frontières puisque le variant circulent
déjà en france qui prend part d'yves
mans puisque ce variant il est présent
ou l'a vu dans la dernière heure pour
l'influent belgique on l'a vu en
autriche regardez l'autriche c'est un
cas assez intéressant ils sont confinés
et pourtant ils ont le variant qui est
même apparu on peut simplement freiner
éventuellement sa diffusion mais
j'allais dire quel est l'intérêt
premièrement il faut gagner du temps la
fermeture des frontières c'est pas
parfait ça ne marche pas à tous les
coups c'est même très peureux mais ça
permettrait ça c'est le centre de
contrôle des maladies européennes qu'il
a écrit hier ça permettrait de gagner
probablement deux semaines est ce que
cette étude publiée dans nature en 2006
indiquait déjà il est peu probable que
les restrictions aux frontières et où
les restrictions de voyages internes
retard de la propagation de plus de 2 à
3 semaines à moins qu'elle ne soit
efficace à plus de 99% le plan national
de prévention et de lutte contre une
pandémie grippale publié en 2011
souligné que le contrôle des entrées sur
le territoire pouvait être utile et
seulement en début d'épidémie ce stade
de freinage consiste à retarder
l'introduction de la maladie sur le
territoire
un contrôle sanitaire aux frontières
n'est efficace qu'au début de l'épidémie
l'interruption des vols vers les
destinations touchées est une mesure
ayant peu d'effet donc encore une fois
le contrôle ou la fermeture des
frontières on est efficace qu'en amont
de l'épidémie c'est ce qu'on a pu
remarquer plus tôt au cours de la
pandémie de covile 19 début le delta on
a eu deux trois cas en belgique et puis
bonal la france n'était pas touchée puis
on a commencé à avoir quelques cas en
france quand effectivement on a commencé
à fermer les frontières le virus était
déjà là à titre d'exemple la nouvelle
zélande qui avait opté pour une
stratégie zéro co vide avec
l'instauration de quarantaine
obligatoire la fermeture des frontières
et un traçage des cases approfondie a
choisi d'abandonner cette politique le 2
décembre enfin une nouvelle piste pour
pallier la propagation de nouveaux
variants sans avoir à fermer les
frontières qui a été proposé par
philippe juvin mais aussi par christian
estrosi en février 2021 serait
d'analyser les eaux usées des avions à
leur atterrissage quand un avion
atterrit eh bien on étudie dans les
toilettes de l'avion on recherche il ya
du gros navires et une étude publiée
dans le journal travel medicine en
juillet 2020 démontre que cette solution
pouvait être complémentaire au traçage
des passagers débarquant et aux tests
que nous connaissons
détecter un variant au corps extrêmement
rare en faisant ça à mon avis ça va
coûter très très cher frère unique qui
serait déjà bien enclenchée si vous avez
une seule personne qui malade dans un
avion et qui est allé une fois aux
toilettes les culés 70 ans qu'il faut
aller aussi je ne suis pas certain qu'on
a les moyens techniques de détecter la
présence du variant ses coups pour
l'heure le variant omicron a été classé
of concern ou préoccupa en français par
l'om est et le gouvernement rappelait le
30 novembre que pour le moment il n'est
pas prévu de fermer les frontières
[Musique]